the award sees is a great time of the
year and it's very exciting there you
get to see all these movies and there
seems to be like this huge concentration
of wonderful film suddenly available I
try to see as many movies as possible in
theaters the notion of voting really did
change change some of the way I look at
films I honestly feel that if you're
going to vote on something you need to
be as informed as you can and you need
to understand what the field is you want
to understand what all the options could
be and not just vote on one that you
like because you've seen them you have
to put out all put it pushed aside all
your special affinities and affections
for people you know people you like and
I just will make my decisions based on
the work I won't put a film in thinking
I'm going to sit and judge this filming
full my arms I'll look at them in terms
of what I think the achievement was what
they were trying to do in relationship
to what was achieved I'll respond to the
same thing that I've always responded to
in watching films with which is
hopefully it while I was watching it did
it did it make me forget I was watching
a movie did it make me forget that this
world is really not real that I did it
draw me in and what was my gut reaction
when it was over you know I think a lot
of people think you just sit down and so
for all your friends I think the wedding
is when you don't vote for a friend and
then you kind of hope they don't find
out in the Academy each branch of the
Academy nominates people within that
branch in other words the
cinematographers will nominate the
cinematography award and editors will
nominate the editors and so forth so
really the nominations are a
representation of what other members of
the Academy who do the same thing think
about it when I'm voting for a visual
effects award I'm thinking very much
about the craft and what the
contribution of the visual effects have
been to that film and how they're moving
the craft forward technically
technologically and creatively but in
the other categories when I get to vote
for them i get to be much more a
filmmaker and just appreciate the art of
the film when I vote from my branch I
usually look very thoroughly ball
most of our costumes does it fit the
character or two coloreds does it fit
the background is it harmonious among
all these characters and when I vote I
think the second round to vote I'm
looking more of the story what's the
most entertaining the Overlook of the
film the truth is I have been lucky to
get nominated a fair number of times and
won a fair number times it never gets
easier people always ask well it must be
old hand if you if you were lucky enough
to win you must be able to just run up
there and make a smooth speech or you
must not have flop sweat sitting in the
theater and it's been exactly as hard
honestly at every Academy where they
hate to admit this but I at the very
last nanosecond I think lose lose lose I
was nominated for an Academy Award and I
never was so scared in my life it was
about seven weeks between the
announcements of the nomination and the
ceremony and it was the most terrifying
time I ever live through nothing can
prepare you to speak on TV in front of a
billion people in four thousand you know
Hollywood bigwigs you know winning an
award is great but being nominated also
is a very very special achievement it's
an award into itself and that is
something you know forever in my career
will be one of the things that I'm most
proud of is being nominated for that
award for the best original screenplay
oscar for toy story well watching the
oscars since i was a kid it was always
the unpredictability of it you never
really as much as you thought you know
who was going to win you really never
knew it's a shared memory for this are a
big part of our society in fact the
Oscars and whether you're a celebrity or
somebody who's actually an Oscar winner
or whether you're you know somebody who
just happens to like movies you you
really have that same that that in
common and and the fun of sort of
watching who's going to win and you know
what's going to happen and and
reminiscing what did happen is
is pretty fun pretty exciting